hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast unravel the Exim Odyssey
overcome the challenges of X on level
cnv detection presented by dr. al
khattab a director cytogenetics
laboratory greenwood genetic center and
dr. christina coos mono ozog medical
geneticists Children's National Medical
Center I'm Alexis Krause of lab routes
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminars
brought to you by lab routes and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information on our sponsor
please visit thermo Fisher com now let's
get started before we begin I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
and click on the send button well answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window click on the arrows
at the top right hand corner of the
slide window if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credit please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right at the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits
I'd like to now introduce our two
presenters speaking first is dr.
Kristina cusimano ozog dr. Kristina coos
Mona ozog earned her medical degree at
the University of South Florida where
she also completed her training in
pediatrics
she then relocated the Stanford
University for training in medical
genetics and clinical biochemical
genetics cheering on staff for three
years before moving to Washington DC
where she accepted a faculty position at
Children's National in 2011 in 2014 she
took a brief hiatus to obtain additional
training in clinical molecular genetics
through the National Institutes of
Health dr. cusamano ozog is a BMG
certified in clinical genetics clinical
biochemical genetics and clinical
molecular genetics currently she is an
attending physician in the division of
genetics metabolism and co-directs the
biochemical genetics and the human
molecular diagnostics laboratory at
Children's National in Washington DC dr.
Chari came to the Greenwood genetic
Center in 2008 as a clinical
cytogenetics fellow after completing her
fellowship in July 2010 she assumed the
position of Assistant Director at the
site of genetics laboratory and was
promoted to director in 2013 dr. Chau
Bay is responsible for overseeing the
routine side of genetics chromosome
analysis a molecular cytogenetics
fluorescence in situ hybridization and
genome-wide DNA microarray testing
perform in the cytogenetics laboratory
dr. Java is also currently involved in
the interpretation of microarray test
results as well several research
projects at GGC
she is double board certified inside of
genetics and molecular genetics by the
American Board of Medical Genetics I
will now turn the presentation over to
dr. Cristina quiz Mona goes off and dr.
al khattab a welcome doctor's hello
today I would like to just start by
saying thank you for the opportunity to
be able to show you some of the exciting
work that we've been able to do with
Children's National specifically using
the exon array system I'd like to just
start by reviewing the importance of
copy number variation as we all know it
is an important determination of human
diversity and plays a significant role
in disease susceptibility
generally speaking every individual has
about a 1.2 percent difference between
themselves and the reference genome in
an exact study of almost 60,000
individuals over one hundred and twenty
six thousand copy number variants were
identified in the autosomal protein
coding genes
on average individuals possess almost
one whole deleted gene and almost two
duplicated genes 70% carry at least one
rare genic copy number variation 84% of
copy number variants are shorter than
100 Kb and 56 are shorter than 20 KB
most of these would be missed by
traditional sniffer ray technology the
clinic at Children's National is one of
the largest genetics programs in the
United States and last year there were
over 7,000 patient encounters there's a
wide variety of individuals and
diagnosed he's seen in the clinic
approximately 500 individuals were seen
for developmental delay and additional
500 received for autism and about 1,100
were identified to have an importer of
metabolism typically the evaluation of a
patient in the genetics clinic includes
the recommendation for genetic testing
and if a specific syndrome is not
identified in that initial visit and/or
the individual is noted to have
developmental delays multiple congenital
anomalies or intellectual disabilities
the first two tests recommendation is
chromosomal microarray this has been
suggested by the American College of
medical genetics and numerous other
organizations molecular genetic testing
at Children's National first began in
2013 when we went live with the situs
kin HD system in that first year of
testing postnatal cases or pediatric
cases we ran approximately 800
microarrays
and has been mentioned this is the first
year testing for chromosomal imbalances
associated with intellectual disability
multiple congenital anomalies and autism
in August of 2014 we transitioned over
to the cider scan DF system which is the
FDA cleared array platform again this is
approved for postnatal use in cases of
developmental delay intellectual
disability multiple congenital anomalies
and dysmorphic features in general we
continue to run eight to nine hundred
micro arrays a year primarily on
patients within children's national
about twenty percent of the time we are
able to identify a copy number variation
and about five to ten percent of the
time we identify significant areas of
homozygosity that may be suggestive of
you know parental destiny and or the AO
age is suggestive of parental consent
quantity once we had chromosomal
microarray up and running and
comfortably in the workflow in our
laboratory the next step for us was to
go live with next-gen sequencing we
chose a different way to approach
next-gen sequencing we do not offer
whole exome sequencing at this point of
time and are primarily running panel
based testing on the web bench side we
treat each sample the same and we
sequence all of the genes associated
with known disorders and Elam's so in
other words we're running a medical
exome and we are taking a personalized
approach to the analysis and
interpretation by offering either panels
based on phenotypes and we're using the
findings from chromosomal microarrays
where areas of homozygosity of the night
a side
to identify a recessive disorder
additionally if this test is negative we
allow our physicians to take a second
look typically not inquire the second
charge for this when we went live with
our next-gen sequencing the clinicians
were very active in advocating for the
use of copy number analysis as being
part of the next-gen sequencing testing
we attempted to validate copy number
analysis also referred to as delta p--
analysis bioinformatics using their
next-gen data and we set this out by
taking your sequencing data through BWI
and gatk and generating a band file and
feeding it into the next gene software
by Sauk genetics we are analyzing a
sample compared to controls using a
hidden Markov model during their
validation we analyzed 122 copy numbers
109 had been previously identified
including 66 deletions ranging from a
single exon of 50 base pairs to 25 point
2 mega bassists additionally we looked
at 43 duplications
for chromosome duplications ranging in 8
and the remainder rate ranging in size
from 0.2 KB to 30.8 mega bases we were
able to verify 7 negative samples and a
couple of things which we were not
expecting included 4 samples where we
were unable to detect an exon level copy
number and 2 samples where copy number
variations were identified all of the
prior
chest was deemed negative to focus in on
these incorrect copy number falls by
next-gen sequencing the for single exon
copy number that were not identified
included a duplication of DMD exon 17
and the following deletions X 1/10 of er
CC 6xm 11 of shank two and exon five of
bat Brad to the to copy number changes
that were not identified by traditional
microarray analysis included a deletion
of exons five to ten of CH RNA seven and
a deletion of exon 27 and l1 camp in
other words these deletions were too
small to be picked up by the traditional
microarray platform in our laboratory
therefore the results of our validation
showed us that there are limitations
including single exon copy numbers to be
identified by Owen preventively with
next-gen data as for of eleven of these
cases were not identified by
automatically this led us to the
conclusion that we would need to have
additional confirmation of copy number
calls if a copy number call was
identified bioinformatics and the
options include using a second platform
such as the exon or a system or a
secondary method of calling cnvs such as
a Bayesian model the site of scan
exonerate platform was available for us
to first test in April 2017 and training
was completed in October 17 Sanders can
exonerate kids are now available for
purchase kits can be used with the
existing Thermo Fisher Scientific
equipment as I mentioned in our lab we
have been running both Saito scan HD in
saitou-san DX so we had all of the
necessary equipment ready to bring this
tests into our laboratory
simply by purchasing the additional
reagent kits
additionally we were able to establish a
workflow so that the medtech currently
aside to proud situs can DX assay on a
weekly basis is also able to prep the
site of scan exon array at the same time
this is also allowed us to do this
testing in-house with no additional use
of FTEs one of the first things we
looked at was the in current copy number
calls by next-gen and we were actually
able to identify these calls with the
sight of an exon all right kit so
looking at the for single exon copy
numbers that were missed bioinformatics
the DMD duplication as of three other
deletions we were able to identify these
with the exon or a kit in this slide you
will see a screen shot of the Macra to
deletion and exon 5 I'd like to now go
through a couple of case examples and
this is specifically this is a case of
an individual of maple syrup urine
disease who is identified shortly after
birth maple syrup urine disease is one
of the classical import errors of
metabolism that results from an enzyme
deficiency and the inability to break
down the branched-chain amino acids
leucine isoleucine and valine treatment
for this condition is lifelong and will
either be by reduced protein and take
special metabolic formula and/or liver
transplantation when this individual was
a adolescent they were evaluated for
transplant and at that point in time
molecular testing was obtained to try to
identify the underlying molecular
diagnosis in this individual maple syrup
urine disease in MSU D there are four
different genes that create three
different subunits that go to make the
entire enzyme that this individual had
all four gene sequenced by next-gen
sequencing and a single very
and in the DBT gene was identified there
was no second hit in the street
identified and there were no additional
variants identified and the other three
genes known to be positive for MSU D we
were able to take residual sample and
run the cytoscape axon array
specifically then looking at the DBT
gene to see if we could find a second
hit and in this particular situation we
were very excited when we identified a
single deletion of X onto one of the
things unique about working in a
Children's Hospital with testing being
done almost exclusively on the patients
within the hospital is that we were able
to have good knowledge of the other
patients with these disorders and/or
other molecular diagnosis within our
patient cohort there have been several
other individuals with maple syrup urine
disease who have been found to have
deletion of exon 2 within the DBT gene
within our patient population however
those individuals were noted to have
homozygous deletions of DVT which were
easily identified by the next-gen
sequencing so it's really exciting when
we found the cetera zygous deletion as
it had been missed by our bioinformatics
Delta analysis we then looked at some
proficiency test samples and
specifically these are samples for the
gene and colon one um this gene is
responsible for condition known as V
biloba doses type form which is a
recessive neurodegenerative lysosomal
disorder characterized by intellectual
disability and also biologic
abnormalities there are two founder
mutations of the Ashkenazi Jewish
population one being a missense
population and the other being a 6.4 kV
deletion which is responsible for
disease in approximately 95 percent of
individuals of Ashkenazi Jewish descent
in the screen shot you can see the two
proficiency samples both having
deletions of exons one through six with
some minor variation between the two
samples and the size of the deletion
next we evaluated several
Coryell samples and I should note at
this point in time that there was one
sample from Coryell that we were not
able to identify the deletion by any
means so that would include not only
this exon array system but also the site
of scan dxis stem our next-gen
sequencing system and our bioinformatics
del dupe system we did contact Coryell
to notify them that we were unable to
confirm the deletion and they had
informed us at that point in time that
they do not confirm the molecular
results of the samples that are in that
repository and so we went ahead and
ended testing of several different
Coryell samples in part to test out the
exon or a platform and in part to ensure
that the Coryell samples we had really
truly had the deletions that were listed
in this particular sample this is a
Coryell sample from a 35 year old female
with short stature and madelyn deformity
additionally she has several effective
family members including a daughter with
Larry wild syndrome
and here you can see a deletion of most
of the exons of the shop student but not
all of the exons one of the things I
would like to point out with this sample
is up here in the upper right corner the
total number of calls when we first
started doing exon array I was somewhat
hesitant over the possibility of having
several hundred calls to be made per
sample however I was reassured in the
first run as most of the samples have
about thirty calls which is typical for
a patient sample in our laboratory using
the situs candy axis tum' additionally
the probes are clustered into the exons
and clinically significant genes are at
the level one tier there are four tiers
total and there's the ability to alter
the filters of the system with the
default being level one analysis but
should that analysis be negative there
is an opportunity to expand out to level
two or three or four to look at other
possible copy number variations
depending on what you're looking for in
our laboratory since we're only
sequencing genes that have known
clinical phenotypes most of our
evaluation of samples through exon are
looking at the tier 1 or level 1 the
next Orioles sample that I would like to
show you is that belonging to a nine
year old male with methyl Luna chronic
acid area on neutropenia and failure to
thrive this is a syndrome Loomis Barth
syndrome and typically results for
alterations of the Tazz gene this is
located on the X chromosome and what you
can see
here and the screenshot is a total
deletion of the task gene the final
example that I would like to show you
belongs to a 22 year old male with two
strands muscular dystrophy it was
diagnosed at age 10 with calf I first
Rafi progressive muscle weakness and to
walking and what you can see here is a
single exon deletion of exon 45 and so
these are some of the early examples
that we have bringing this system into
our laboratory we've only been running
since October and have not yet validated
or brought this into actual use so this
is still very much in the research
setting in our laboratory and our
proposed strategy for moving forward is
to continue to evaluate patients in
clinic and in that initial evaluation if
a genetic disorder is not identified and
or the patient is noted to have
intellectual disability multiple
congenital anomalies or dysmorphic
features we will continue to offer and
run the saitou-san DX assay as our first
tier testing should that testing will be
negative we will then move on to
next-gen sequencing either by a panel or
phenotype based review of the data and
if a variant is found in a recessive
condition that is appropriate for the
patient we will be able to run the
cytoscape exon array to see if we can
find the deletion or duplication to
provide that individual with a second
hit this could be demonstrated by the
case I shared with you of the individual
with the exon 2 deletion with DBT
additionally um when we were running
next-gen sequencing if a dell dupe is
found violin dramatically we will be
able to verify this call using the
exonerate finally some individuals will
move on to whole exome sequencing when
no disorder is identified oftentimes in
the clinic we are left with the results
of whole exome sequencing identifying
one variant and a recessive disorder
with no second hint in this situation we
would be able to use the X dot array to
follow up the whole exome sequencing to
ensure and dil dupe was not missed on
the other allele so thank you for your
time today and I'd also like to thank
both the Children's National rare
disease Institute division of genetics
and metabolism where the individuals are
evaluated for genetic disorders as well
as the children's molecular diagnostics
lab that is amazing to be in a
Children's Hospital where we have both
the robust clinical operation and
laboratory operation and are able to
feed off of each other thank you for
your time I am one of the directors of
the side to genomics laboratory I'd
clean with genetic Center and so I'll be
talking about how we are using the site
and Exxon suite a green with genetic
Center with some examples here are my
disclaimers so as dr. cusamano just
mentioned that in a postnatal genetic
workup chromosomal mercury has been
recommended as the first line test by a
number of agencies such as the American
Academy of Pediatrics American Academy
of Neurology American College of medical
genetics and genomics and other agencies
what that essentially pertains to is
that if an individual comes
with developmental delay intellectual
disability multiple congenital anomalies
autism dysmorphic features and seizures
then what kind of testing should be done
first and chromosomal my jury made the
first line test now this has been going
on since 2010 when these agencies
recommended this testing as the first
line test so at the Greenwood genetic
Center we have been running my purees
since 2008 and we have a nice tie up
with our molecular lab and to kind of
complement all of your testing and Saito
genomic testing so if an individual
comes in with developmental delay
intellectual disability or multiple
congenital anomalies since we have an
FDA cleared assay which is the site of
scan DX assay we do run those samples on
this asset if we identify a pathogenic
microti lesion on multiplication that
essentially ends the diagnostic Odyssey
of fact ation however if we get a normal
or a variant of uncertain significance
results then those individuals are have
to have additional testing done to
identify the genetic cause of their
disorder if a patient comes in with
clinical symptoms such as autism or
seizures or some kind of connective
tissue disorder then we have the non FDA
cleared assay at GGC which is side a
scan HD and those individuals are run on
that platform and again we have the same
kind of pathway that if we do find a
pathogenic change pathogenic deletion or
duplication then that diagnostic Odyssey
for that patient ends over there however
if though if you do not have a positive
or pathogenic finding and if you have a
variant of uncertain significance then
those patients may be subjected to whole
exome sequencing or other gene
sequencing panels now as you can see on
the right
side of this graph is those those
patients whether they were on the FDA
feared as a or on the non FDA tear gas a
whole exome sequencing on a platform
that is used to clean with genetic
Center includes almost 5,000 genes and
those that is called the clinical
research exome and based on that we can
have a single gene a variant finding a
single nucleotide variant short in bills
however to complement those genes we had
to have a custom del dupe array which we
kind of design based on all our short
panels like connective tissue panel
autism panel XL ID panel and those were
run as a compliment
with our NGS panels to identify a del
dupe especially for an autosomal
recessive disorder if we only identified
one change by sequencing or to look for
a deletion or duplication for an
autosomal dominant disorder where we
only found where we didn't find any
changes by sequencing asses so this is
essentially how the site of genomics and
the molecular genomics lab at the new
genetics Center tie up together and work
towards providing services to these
patients so but in terms of doing del
dupe assay to complement gene sequencing
we have a number of challenges for the
actual setup so we had a number of MLP a
assays and for those of the labs that
have experience with this you can
realize that every run first of all
require several controls and it's
actually a per x1 as a so that means
that the cost can vary by the test and
it's really not comprehensive for a
number of gene panels or lists so it has
its own advantages and a number of
limitations if we look at a custom dell
do assay which is what we move genetic
Center had till we got site ask an exon
so
so one of the biggest challenges is that
with new literature and new findings the
list of medically relevant genes are
growing so that means that these custom
designs need to be kept updated we need
to add more genes so what does that
happen for a laboratory developed tests
in a cat clear setting which is one of
the criteria of a diagnostic lab in the
United States and elsewhere so that puts
a significant validation burden for new
designs and of course then that also
hinders the lab management and
efficiency because how many times are
you going to do a validation when you
have a platform that has another 10 or
100 or 200 genes added to it so that was
one of the biggest challenges why we
were not ever able to update our 725
king list for the past 4 years
then another assay that we tried to
validate was the medical research XO
memory which was a 1 million array which
only had copy number profound it did not
have any snips on it and when we try to
do our mini validation we found that it
had and exceptionally high false
positive rate the other thing was it was
very expensive so we are trying to
provide a delta passe to complement our
next-gen panels or our whole exome
sequencing it it turned out to be a
pretty expensive assay for the lab and
would have put a significant burden on
the patients and families that needed
this testing the other thing was that
even this assay is not totally
future-proof so what does that mean so
that this assay also only had roughly
4600 genes on it so what happens when
your genes are identified and are
associated with disorders then again
what kind of validation or development
that is needed over there so given the
limitations of the different assays out
there available for labs to validate one
of the things that we have to really
realize is done
arrey is really useful to dictate x1
level series and as you just saw from
dr. cusamano talk that even though you
can have nice NGS or whole exome
sequencing algorithms to pick up
deletions duplications or CNVs
we still have a lot of false positives
and false negatives and so a whole exome
array ideally has been reported and
shown by different studies that it can
be an extremely useful tool to confirm
the findings by whole exome sequencing
and especially for autosomal dominant
disorders when next-generation
sequencing is negative or autosomal
recessive disorders when we have only
found one change by sequencing and also
you know on an exome array we want to be
able to reliably detect symboliks ancien
these because they could be the the
causative reason reason for the genetic
etiology of a specific disorder in a
patient so with this background we're
what we wanted to see was that we're
next-generation sequencing in microarray
complement each other and so cycle scan
exon suite was a big path forward in
terms of development for the array
content and design and we at Greenville
genetic Center we're fortunate to be
involved from the beginning in terms of
what kind of gene panels should be on it
what should be the coverage how many
probes at a minimum would be needed and
I have to really applaud the applied
Biosystems or thermo Fisher team that
the way that they selected the six point
eight five million best probes which
includes 300,000 snail probes was
empirically selected to determine a copy
number response and so the other big
advantage of this platform is that this
covers almost 26,000 genes and as dr.
Kuzma know men
that you know you saw in some of her
class as I will show you to that level 1
to level 4 or how these genes are
classified so level 1 genes which is
almost 7,000 genes are essentially the
ones that are only morbid genes are
genes associated with specific disorders
intellectual disability autism other
metabolic disorders and then the level
two genes are those genes that have a
claim or entry and level 3 are other
immune genes that may or may not be
associated with a specific disease or
disorder and level 4 are the genes that
have refseq UCSC and ensembl entries the
other big advantage of this platform is
that when the probes in the target exon
were being designed and developed it was
it was decided at the level 1 genes
which have the highest clinical
relevance we've also have truths in the
flanking regions of the target exon
whereas the other level genes may will
have at least a lot of probes in the
target exon may or may not have been
invasions covered so this was also very
helpful in terms of looking at some
regulatory regions or some five prime
three prime UTR regions that could or
could not be clinically significant for
these selected genes so in terms of a
validation and how this whole
development was taking place what our
observation was that psycho spandex on
had a lot of fewer calls compared to the
medical research exome reading so if you
look at this table here and there are
five samples that were compared on both
sides and exon and the Emory array what
you can see that the total number of
calls were two times less on the exon
array as compared to the Emory array now
in terms of a clinical lab in terms of a
diagnostic setting where we have to
report these findings it becomes
extremely important to have a number of
calls that we can be confident about
now you have to understand that this is
not an an apples-to-apples comparison
because psycho spandex on has 26,000
genes and the MRI array only has four
point six thousand genes if we do an
apples-to-apples comparison which is on
the right side of the table what we see
that the number of calls are 11 times
less so if you go back to my point as I
was trying to explain in terms of false
positive calls on the other platforms
this was a huge benefit to the lab in
terms of resources in terms of
confirming these calls and in terms of
providing this information to our
refering clinicians and families so we
were extremely happy with the
development and this data set the other
thing is that for the labs that are
already using the platforms available
since 2010 as was the case at Greenwood
genetics Center we have the software
which is provided by thermo Fisher which
is chromosome analysis 3 and you saw
some snippets in end of the cusamano's
talk and you can see that it is
extremely easy to use the software and
it has been updated for the
interpretation of cytostatics on data
and as I mentioned earlier we can do
just a tier 1 to tier 4 analysis and not
look at other genes or gene panels or
gene sets if you're not interested in
that the other thing is that we can
easily create bed files of select genes
that we are interested in and we can
look at those target genes and restrict
the view of only those genes that we are
interested in and not look at other
noise or other you know calls that may
or may not be clinically significant and
another feature is that is
next-generation sequencing or whole
exome sequencing has been performed on
the same patient then we have the
opportunity to integrate the VCF file to
look for combined viewing so as we have
just seen based on the development
validation side-scan exxon state has one
of the highest resolutions with
increased coverage available in the
market today it contains six point eight
five million probes of with six point
five are copy number probes and three
hundred thousand are snip rows this is
extremely important as we saw in one of
our validation samples that the snips
can show us mosaic loss of
heterozygosity or mosaic UPT in a
constitutional setting
secondly this is one of the most
superior
future-proof design because now it
covers twenty six thousand genes for
deletion duplication detection and has
almost coverage of 7,000 genes of the
most relevant genes associated with
genetic disorders and clinical research
and just the inclusion of snips for the
identification of loss of heterozygosity
absence of heterozygosity sample
identity and the ability to perform new
and true studies is extremely beneficial
and helpful too and the flexible
analysis that we can do in the software
now to look at single or multi exon
level deletions or duplications or to
look at specific channel or gene lists
to look at our data for the specific
phenotype that has been provided to us
in terms of the patient is also
extremely useful for a lab setting so
now I'd like to switch gears and show
you to research cases that VLAN is part
of the early access study the research
case one is a Waardenburg syndrome
category which you can see on the bottom
left right left side of the slide and
you can see that there the probe and
which is shown with the arrow is this
fetus which is affected so this was a
fetus on exam at 32 weeks and on
ultrasound at 32 weeks showed fixed
limbs a scalp edema and micrognathia
which is a small jump and you can see
but on the fetal exam this was a
stillborn this fetal exam the fetus had
white hair had small palpebral fissures
and ears and also had a cleft palate
which you can see in the middle
photograph the cresting in the mouth and
had excessive nuchal skin which is
around the neck and had four limb Torito
syndactyly absent palmar creases and
some other genital abnormalities so the
the clinical phenotype obviously was
Waardenburg syndrome and on this slide
you can see this is the mother of the
affected features and there was another
affected male child who had deafness and
skin pigmentation issues and you can see
this iris heterochromia you can see the
blue colored iris in one of her eyes and
so if you look at what is known about
Waardenburg syndrome there are four
types of Waardenburg syndrome and there
are different genes that have been
associated with those syndromes so the
first thing that we did was we ran this
this specimen on our HD microarray and
we identified a large deletion on
chromosome 22 which includes the sox10
gene so you can see that sox10 gene is
responsible for almost 15 percent of
Waardenburg syndrome type 2 cases and
almost 50% of Waardenburg syndrome type
4 cases we did run the Waardenburg
syndrome panel and or five genes and we
did not have any single nucleotide
variants we did run whole exome
sequencing and we did not have a finding
so when we ran this case on site as an
exon what we saw what what you can see
on the on the top part of the array
image is this large light red deletion
and with those heavy red boxes it is
showing us a nested homozygous deletion
so we did do a qpcr studies and we
tested the parents
we saw that the mother was the carrier
of the large deletion and the father was
the carrier of the smaller deletion and
both of them are affected and of course
the features with the by allelic
deletion was the stillborn which has
more severe features we have submitted
this case report for publication to
American Journal of medical genetics and
it is pending acceptance right now so
this was really extremely interesting
that now not only do we have the ability
to pick up large deletions but we also
have the ability to pick up nested
homozygous deletions the second case
that I'd like to share is again a very
interesting case that has been followed
up at the game of genetic Center by our
founder director dr. Roger Stephenson so
this is the case of a female with a
calve area and and you can see that
father and one sister and one
half-sister were affected so what a
calvaria means is that almost lack of
the skull bones and the and the
neighboring muscles and you can see that
usually this is associated with some
kind of craniosynostosis phenotype so
the facial appearance looked like crews
on chromium craniosynostosis and what we
saw was that the posterior parietal and
occipital areas of the calvaria were not
ossified which you can see in the x-ray
image of this case so we this case was
also subjected to craniosynostosis
next-gen panel and we did not have any
findings on that panel and all the genes
on this panel where fiber or fibroblast
growth factor receptor one two and three
chains because they have been associated
with craniosynostosis phenotype we did
run a whole exome sequencing and we
found benign variants are some variants
but they were also present in the
paternal sample so they were excluded so
when we run
sighs Oh spandex on is part of early
access what we found so this is the
fgfr4 team and it's really really
amazing that you can see the deletion of
these log two or these copy number
probes over here which is in the three
prime UTR and this is a partial exonic
deletion so we weren't very convinced
that this is a real finding but we did
do quantitative PCR and it confirmed and
by qpcr and we are now pursuing this
further because fgfr4 s have not been
associated with craniosynostosis
findings in the constitutional setting
and although it belongs to the same
family of genes we think that this is a
valid finding but we need to do
additional studies to determine the
functional significance of this finding
so these are two important cases as we
were doing our validation we decided
that we also have a heated III cancer
NGS panel at Greenwood genetics Center
which contains 44 genes and of those 44
genes
PACA one and braca two were on it and
some limb syndrome and familial
polyposis genes and as as part of this
panel copy number determination is
extremely important because there are
some known bracket1 deletions
duplications that are pathogenic so we
used four samples and we put them on
site ask an exon suite as part of the
analysis of these 44 genes we we found
that all the genes had more than 150
probes per gene there were no gaps in
any exon so we performed this mini
validation and recommend bracket
elaborations work and fun and you can
see in this table that all our shell
gain of Rackham on exon 1 to 19 or an
entire gain or bracket one with a
partial gain of graphic two exons one to
three or a large to copy gain or bracket
to all of these cases were 100%
concordance with our previous findings
and so this was
something that we did on the side but
really benefited a lab in terms of a
targeted analysis of an NGS panel in
terms of del Duca analysis so how does
this work so the first step is that on
the right hand side you see chromosome
analysis sweep which is the software
which is used to visualize the array
data and when you click on the sample
you can open the array results and you
can see that there are 47 calls and when
you click on the open target list of
genes we can specify the target list of
genes here in this case it was 44 genes
that we were looking for and when we
filter according to those gene lists
that we are interested in we see that
only one call showed up and this was a
blinded analysis and when we look at
that we can see well it's a it's a it
partially includes the bracket gene even
though the duplication is large enough
and we can zoom in on the gene and even
just look at the gene of intracellular
and not look at the call which is in the
adjacent area also so these are some
unique features which will be extremely
helpful in reporting if we look at so
how has this made this complete story
different in terms of GGC molecular
psycho genomics data so if you go back
to my first slide now I remove the
compartments and now the compartments
show that our del dupe array which was
off of a select number of 725 genes is
now being replaced with psycho spandex
on sweet and the whole and predict that
we will be able to provide answers to
phenotypes and patients and Families and
end their diagnostic Odyssey in summary
in our experience and just looking at
our experience with this platform we
have this future-proof platform which
can be a huge adjunct to whole exome
sequence
and other next generation sequencing
panels for reliable deletion duplication
determination extremely easy to use
and same software for those labs that
are already using applied Biosystems or
thermo Fisher's platform and it's a
similar assay and as dr. rucas mano
mentioned no increase in and FTE and we
can very flexibly slice and dice the
data to look at the genes or panels that
we are interested in one big benefit
also that we've seen is that this uses a
very little input DNA as low as 100 nano
grams which is considerably less from
250 nano grams that we were using
earlier and this has been a kept
cost-effective and cost neutral which is
which is something that you know as a
user and a customer we need to tag these
the provider and the vendor and because
then this does not put an additional
burden on the patients and families that
need this testing and an exceptionally
lower number of calls then other
platforms and other assays that we have
struggled with in the past with that I
would like to end and and I'm open for
questions and comments what you can see
on the left left side is the photograph
of all the GTC employees and this is our
lingo genetic Center treatment center
building and on the right hand side you
see the GGC site Oh genomics lab and we
were all viewing blue for autism blue
tape thank you thank you dr. travail and
dr. Kuzma no ozog for your informative
presentations we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button well answer as many
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is going to
be for dr. Kuzma no azar have you tested
any mosaic Sam
with this new platform if so what have
you found
thank you for this question um we have
not yet tested any mosaic samples with
the Exxon or a platform however we do
have several residual samples of mosaic
trisomies identified using the
cytostatics platform that we should be
able to test the system with question
number two is going to be for dr. Shah
Bay have you looked at known pseudogene
region PM PM s2 or msh2 etc and what are
your findings um thank you for this
question - um no we have not looked at
these pseudo gene regions yet but when
when we start running our edit or cancer
panels we anticipate that we will be
able to have a little bit more
experience with these genes and try to
figure out a real call in the team
versus the pseudo gene but right now we
don't have any experience with this dr.
Kuzma know how many probes are you using
to make your calls um so we have not
altered the filter settings we're using
the standard settings that came with the
software when we open up a sample we are
identifying between 20 and 60 calls in a
sample and thus far we've only run
samples where we had targeted deletions
or duplications to look at so we we've
pretty much gone in and identified that
the target that we were looking for and
and it just sort of played around a
little bit with the additional calls but
we've not analyzed a sample blindly
or without a specific indication okay
and we have time for one more question
dr. Chow Bay how does the number of
calls you see on the XO Narae compared
to others you used those do you find
that you're able to validate more of
those calls on one array over the other
yes actually as I was showing in my
slides that the number of calls on the X
on array were 11 times less than the
other platform that we tried to validate
a teen with genetics Center which was a
huge number of decrease in the false
positives so that's the first part in
terms of validating those calls on one
or over the other so as you can imagine
having 11 times more calls and trying to
validate those most of those would turn
out to be false positives we were not
able to confirm by any other methodology
on the other hand if you look at my
fgfr4 case it was a partial exonic
deletion of the last exon which is the
3-prime utr and it had very few number
of probes and even though the software
did not make that call but you can just
see that during visualization we saw the
decrease in the log 2 ratio and we were
able to confirm that by qPCR any
positive result that I have shown in the
to research cases and the other cases
that we have at GGC we have been able to
confirm by quantitative PCR on the exon
array versus the other platforms where
we had majority being false positives
thank you again doctors do either of you
have any final comments for our audience
I would like to recommend any diagnostic
lab running my Curie's as a diagnostic
or a validated LDT that they should
definitely consider using the exon side
scan exon suite as a complement to the
next generation sequencing panels as my
recommendation hey can I just
chime in and answer the mosaic question
I'd like
give a comment so as part of the early
access study we did have a sample where
we were able to identify a chromosome 6p
UPD was a QP D on the side scan exon
suite so I can confidently tell you that
just having the snip probes on this
platform is a huge advantage to be able
to identify I so died so me and also
mosaic you PDS uniparental die so nice
perfect
I would like to once again thank dr.
Cristina Cruz Mona ozog and dr.
al-kitabi for their presentations I
would also like to thank lab roots and
thermo Fisher for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I'd like to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through July 2018 you
will receive an email from laboratory
you - when this webcast is available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event that's all for
now thank you for joining us and we hope
to see you again soon goodbye